hier soir dans un geste très fort le
cardinal lustiger avait annoncé
l'effroyable nouvelle en éteignant hier
soir les sept sièges des cierges qui
symbolisait la vie des sept trappistes
enlevés le 27 mars
le texte du gia était toujours alors en
cours d'authentification mais les
experts déjà n'avait guère de doute
françois cordet le texte daté du 21 mai
portant le numéro 44 et de cachets
habituel du gia est signée par le chef
présumé du groupe islamique armé
jamais le site uni il accuse le
président français le ministre des
affaires étrangères d'avoir déclaré
josip ne pas vouloir négocier avec le
gia
le 30 avril trente quatre jours après
l'enlèvement des sept moines trappistes
dans leur monastère
nous avons envoyé poursuit le communiqué
un message et à l'ambassade de france à
alger
porteur d'une cassette audio confirmant
que les sept religieux étaient vivants
et un message précisant la façon de
négocier pour obtenir leur libération
l'ambassade précise le communiqué nous a
écrit une lettre signée et cachetée
affirmant qu'elle voulait préserver cet
accord nous avons donc pensé dans un
premier temps que la france tenait à la
vida sept moines
fin de citation malgré ces tractations
secrètes
les forces de sécurité algériennes
poursuivre leur chasse à l'homme en vain
selon l'évêque d'oran les ravisseurs
seraient venus à tibéhirine pour emmener
un seul moine médecin afin de soigner
des islamistes blessés
les religieux français avait choisi de
continuer à vivre dans leur monastère
dans une région de maquis du gia
malgré la présence des moudjahidine
qu'ils avaient surnommés les frères de
la montagne le second mobile de
l'enlèvement des sept moines révélé le
26 avril dernier par le quotidien arabe
al hayat et l échange proposé aux
autorités françaises des sept otages
contre la libération des militants du
gia emprisonnés et notamment abdelhak
layada ancien dirigeant du groupe
condamné à mort et détenu en algérie
[Musique]